this is the moment that has shocked
viewers in America a pregnant woman with
her two children faced with armed
officers threatening to shoot she been
out shopping with her partner in a
dollar store in Phoenix while there the
pair of them didn't notice when one of
the children picked up a door which
wasn't paid for alerted by other
shoppers the storekeeper called the
police who followed the family's vehicle
before moving in to apprehend them
pulling the driver from the car at
gunpoint and handcuffing him I'm scared
for her they're probably picks up a toy
or something in afraid of getting shot
the family have filed a 10 million
dollar lawsuit against the city and the
police department they claim that ever
since the incident that little girl has
been wetting the bed for their part the
police alleged they repeatedly tried to
get mr. Aames to stop his car but he
wouldn't comply they have since issued
this statement I like you and disturbed
by the language and the actions of our
officer I assure you that this incident
is not representative of the majority of
Phoenix police officers who served this
city as for the storekeeper he has
declined to press charges and no arrests
have been made
meanwhile the police investigation is
continuing Phil Edwards Sky News